[SPEAKER_07]: Actually easier if you don't put stuff like this in there.
There you go, thank you.
People in the country have always just managed to survive.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_09]: Oh, she's not even, she don't have Crystal Lakes information.
[SPEAKER_09]: Gotcha, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can reach out.
[SPEAKER_04]: She just probably doesn't know which one's going to happen, right?
[SPEAKER_09]: What I can do is try to reach out to Crystal Lakes and see if they have information for their special membership.
[SPEAKER_09]: And if I do get it, I can reach out to them.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is it, did they have one?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll just call them and see if they say no and I'll come back and ask you again.
Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good morning, Miranda.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good morning.
[SPEAKER_09]: How are you?
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm good, how are you?
[SPEAKER_09]: Good.
[SPEAKER_09]: You get over out of school?
[SPEAKER_09]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's ripped.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does that make it easier for you or more difficult?
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a really great sitter, so it really doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_09]: You said don't wander me.
[SPEAKER_09]: Either way, she's gone throughout the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I think it is 9 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we have a motion to call the meeting?
[SPEAKER_02]: So moved.
[SPEAKER_02]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, this meeting is officially in order.
[SPEAKER_02]: And has everyone signed in at the back?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we're being recorded.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, and videoed.
[SPEAKER_02]: So who is first on the list?
[SPEAKER_09]: I think Laura would have a comment.
[SPEAKER_09]: Well, thank you.
[SPEAKER_09]: Do I stand?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_08]: You do whatever is comfortable.
[SPEAKER_08]: My name is Laura Chalk.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm from TempCon, and we're a commercial HVAC plumbing and refrigeration company.
[SPEAKER_08]: We had bid on some HVAC equipment for the jail, the Ring County Jail, in early March, and I think we did not win that bid.
[SPEAKER_08]: But I had called in a few weeks ago just to see who I might chat with
[SPEAKER_08]: and see how TempCon could do business with Ray County in the future.
[SPEAKER_08]: And they asked me to show up.
[SPEAKER_08]: So I didn't realize this was a formal meeting.
[SPEAKER_08]: I could walk in and talk with somebody.
[SPEAKER_08]: So I apologize for crashing your meeting.
[SPEAKER_08]: But yes, we do all kinds of commercial work.
[SPEAKER_08]: So whether it's, you know, we work with a lot of the big builders across the metro.
[SPEAKER_08]: So like J.B. Dunn and McCown Gordon and many others like that.
[SPEAKER_08]: So we do everything from installations.
[SPEAKER_08]: on large or small commercial projects so that the HVAC, you know, a lot of time for doing all those installations for big projects.
[SPEAKER_08]: We also do preventative maintenance for, you know, the HVAC equipment, also in refrigeration equipment, ice machines, all kinds of things.
[SPEAKER_08]: So, you know, we work with all different sizes of commercial customers and could be, you know, county or city governments, could be just a regular up and down the street kind of business.
[SPEAKER_08]: And then, yeah, then we do things even like calibrations for laboratory equipment.
[SPEAKER_08]: So, you know, we're in hospitals and labs, and so it's just, we cover a lot of ground.
[SPEAKER_08]: And so I was just hoping to inquire to see who I could chat with and what is the process to do maybe some preventative maintenance business for Wake County.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, the one thing that...
[SPEAKER_02]: I would just comment on, since you all have made a bid and it didn't go to you, you all are doing probably the process that we have in place.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're watching for notices in the newspaper, online, and that's how we get to where we are when we're working with different companies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you all have anything to add?
[SPEAKER_08]: Were you guys always?
[SPEAKER_08]: We're a shiny campus.
[SPEAKER_08]: And we cover a wide swath.
[SPEAKER_08]: So we go even to Topeka and Florence and, you know, where we come up as far.
[SPEAKER_08]: So, yeah, we service a wide area around the whole campus.
[SPEAKER_02]: And your presentation was very good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you for bringing up charges.
[SPEAKER_08]: So our regular market rate for labor is $135 an hour.
[SPEAKER_08]: If a customer is on a preventative maintenance agreement, so we're going out quarterly or semi-annually or we're on some kind of a preventative maintenance agreement,
[SPEAKER_08]: that will go down to $120 an hour.
[SPEAKER_08]: But even the $135 an hour for the labor rate is highly competitive.
[SPEAKER_08]: We have others in our market that charge more than that.
[SPEAKER_08]: We're very customer-focused.
[SPEAKER_08]: Our goal is to build relationships with people and be a real partner to our clients and our customers.
[SPEAKER_08]: We do everything we can to serve people really well and very fairly.
[SPEAKER_08]: We are looking to build relationships.
[SPEAKER_08]: And TedCon has been in business for about 37 years.
[SPEAKER_08]: Have a great track record.
[SPEAKER_06]: You did say refrigeration and freezers.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yes, walk-ins, large commercial stuff, even small reach-ins.
[SPEAKER_08]: as well.
[SPEAKER_08]: So whether it's laboratory or just like restaurants, all different types of refrigeration.
[SPEAKER_08]: Okay, well thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thanks for being here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I leave cards in the room?
[SPEAKER_02]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thanks so much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I appreciate your time today.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we have anything else?
[SPEAKER_02]: Any comments?
[SPEAKER_04]: Kirk Croy, so I submitted a Sunshine request for the voting records when you guys do closed meetings that are related to employee information.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so what the Sunshine law says is that after 72 hours, you're supposed to release the voting record.
[SPEAKER_04]: But for all of 2025, there's nothing.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then for a specific meeting that I asked for that data on in 2026, there's no information.
[SPEAKER_04]: I guess the first question I have is like, what are you guys discussing in those meetings if there is no voting record actually coming out of it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I will just make one comment when we post.
[SPEAKER_02]: that we're having those meetings, the statute topic is included in that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it is under that umbrella what our discussions are about, and then we
[SPEAKER_02]: are not to, I mean, by statute, the way I understand it, those minutes are not available to anyone.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's closed sessions.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if the voting, if, I guess I don't understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: There was no voting continues.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there was no voting.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, there was things discussed, but there wasn't a vote.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that would imply that for all of 2025, no county employees were hired, fired, disciplined, or promoted.
[SPEAKER_06]: Pretty much.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not sure that we even have.
[SPEAKER_08]: Well, each office can do what they want to do.
[SPEAKER_04]: What?
[SPEAKER_08]: Each office can do what they want to do.
[SPEAKER_08]: They are in charge of their own employees, so it doesn't have to go into closed session.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'm not talking about them.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm talking about the meetings that they're having in these closed sessions.
[SPEAKER_06]: That means... We haven't had any meetings on employees to my knowledge.
[SPEAKER_04]: You have.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's why I submitted the Sunshine request and you've had whenever they're going to closed sessions.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so that would mean that no employee was hired, fired...
[SPEAKER_04]: discipline for promoting in 2025 by all?
[SPEAKER_06]: We don't go into closed session to do anything except perhaps discipline.
[SPEAKER_06]: We didn't discipline anybody.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so the answer is yes then.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you hacked in 2025.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes what?
[SPEAKER_06]: The answer is yes what?
[SPEAKER_06]: To what?
[SPEAKER_04]: You just said nobody was disciplined.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so we were hacked in 2025.
[SPEAKER_04]: No one was hired or nobody was fired or disciplined for that, for who was responsible for that or whatever happened that created that vulnerability.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's correct.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: While I know this is your expertise, IT is your expertise, that has nothing to do with what happened here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And we can't discuss it.
[SPEAKER_02]: We got through that.
[SPEAKER_02]: We went through all the legal channels.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had our attorney.
[SPEAKER_02]: We had attorneys that threw our insurance.
[SPEAKER_02]: So none of that is correct, what you're saying.
[SPEAKER_04]: What am I saying that's incorrect?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, we've covered this.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's your next question?
[SPEAKER_04]: That was my question.
[SPEAKER_04]: What I'm saying is incorrect.
[SPEAKER_02]: That you're insisting that someone was fired or disciplined.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not insisting that.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm asking the question, was someone disciplined or fired?
[SPEAKER_06]: We will have you removed.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Um, the next thing that I wanted to ask was, what is going on with this ditch, Max?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because I have been coming in here asking you to get this fixed for over six months now, and nobody is doing anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: So where is the, like, the incompetence?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is it happening with you communicating with the road district or the road district communicating to their employees to do it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Or where is the disconnect here?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because to Bobby Don's point about where you need to be patient and wait, because
[SPEAKER_04]: We don't want to waste gas when it's so high.
[SPEAKER_04]: The guy with the grader has driven, since I've talked to you twice, past my house at least.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's just me happening to see him while I'm outside doing work or whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: So where is this...
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll follow up on it.
[SPEAKER_04]: You've said that to me so many times.
[SPEAKER_04]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who are you following up with?
[SPEAKER_06]: That's what I have for you today.
[SPEAKER_06]: It doesn't make any difference.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't have to answer that to you.
[SPEAKER_06]: You've voiced your complaint.
[SPEAKER_06]: I will follow up on it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Any other comments?
[SPEAKER_02]: Any other comments from anyone else?
[SPEAKER_01]: Toby.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, hello.
[SPEAKER_01]: I've got a chance to speak.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm Jesse with Rake County, number two water district.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we had an instance back on April 24th when a storm came through and a tree fell.
[SPEAKER_01]: And when it fell, it rocked the ground hard enough that it split a pipe over our water mains in the ground.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I paid for a crew to come, two different crews, to come and get your construction.
[SPEAKER_01]: Decker Construction removed the tree and everything like that, while the road district guys stood up by and watched, and I still got charged for a permit fee for working on the road.
[SPEAKER_01]: I didn't believe that was fair, especially since the district paid for the tree to get removed when that should have been the road district's job.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's some roads that have been moved in the past, like 134th and Waller.
[SPEAKER_01]: Used to have a crook in it and a small bridge.
[SPEAKER_01]: You all bypassed the bridge, put collar pipes in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Since that happened, the water washed my main up.
[SPEAKER_01]: I had to relay rip raft and cover my mains back up and different things like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I just don't think it's fair that we always have to pay this permit fee for line crossings or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Especially one of our service,
[SPEAKER_01]: provides for people to build houses and get tax revenue off of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just a little complaint I got and see if I can get some reimbursement for a bill I got for the room and the tree.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, it's all new stuff.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's all brand new, so we'll have to see what's going on with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you have a comment, Paula?
[SPEAKER_00]: I was just going to say I was
[SPEAKER_00]: Just doing my job, requesting the right-of-way permit for the work to be done.
[SPEAKER_00]: I verified with the road district that they, in fact, wanted that done.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I have held the check because it's easier to have a discussion versus doing a refund later.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is there insurance on that?
[SPEAKER_01]: On our water lines?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, sir.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, when we have main breaks and stuff, we pay for it through revenue we get from water sales through the customers.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, and since I've been, I've only been here about two years now, I've been trying to work with Paula as far as the planning and zoning and making sure that we're doing stuff properly for the housing and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: She's wanting to inform me about the permits.
[SPEAKER_01]: I told my contractor we're going to start getting permits for line crossings like we do for highways and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have no issues with that, but whenever we go do something like this and I have to pay a contractor to do the work, just so I can get to my water main and fix my water main, it kind of disrupted me the wrong way that I got charged for a road permit.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can put rock in, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: What road was that on?
[SPEAKER_01]: That was on West 84th Street.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And how long ago?
[SPEAKER_01]: April 24th.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll check into that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, great.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And thanks, Paula, for working and holding the check to figure out what the solution is.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you, Paula.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll get back with you on that after I find this out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: What was your name again?
[SPEAKER_01]: Jesse Howe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesse, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wasn't sure that you got to sign in when we came in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's fine, we have your card.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's just for us to reference, thank you.
Okay, Brian.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that concludes all the public comments, correct?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Brian Couch with the Ray Kennedy Senior Center.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have a phone system that is extremely antiquated.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, we're talking 1980s antiquated, and we're having some issues with that stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: Since our break-in, our board went out and bought some internal cameras and stuff so that we can kind of cover that.
[SPEAKER_03]: But that's all done through our administrator's cell, and he's using his private cell for quite a bit of work.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I'll kind of let the request speak for itself and then kind of let you guys decide on what you want to do with that.
[SPEAKER_03]: But either way, our phone system is not good.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, it drops calls.
[SPEAKER_03]: You don't get good reception.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, it is literally – I think my kids had those kind of phones in high school.
[SPEAKER_03]: It was bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: So are you talking landline phones?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, the landline that we currently have is not good.
[SPEAKER_03]: But what we're asking for is a cell phone so that he can better manage and bring everything up to date and get it a little more up to date to what the needs are.
[SPEAKER_06]: What phone service is that?
[SPEAKER_03]: What phone service?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not sure because you guys pay the bill on that, don't you?
[SPEAKER_06]: I wanted to say AT&T, but I... Well, we dropped AT&T, so I would say probably we might have fired her.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll have to check into all these things.
[SPEAKER_06]: There's some discussion as to who's responsible for the phone in the first place.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, the phone is you guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: I know that.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's on the... Because Trina gave me a list of...
[SPEAKER_08]: So it's Kansas Communications, so we can have them come down there and check it out.
[SPEAKER_03]: But even with that, with the number of things that he has to do on his own personal cell to be able to do his job, why we would ask that if he upgraded to a cell phone port.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I think that has to, the way I understand it, that approval would have to come through you.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I understand, Heather wasn't in the office the day I came up and talked, but my understanding is that there is funds available if you guys approve them.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll have to wait and see.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just want to give you a call.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let me know, let Dave know, or...
[SPEAKER_03]: Do we need to come back to a meeting?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't think we need to come back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Shall we just table this to review, and then we will let you know what our answer is.
[SPEAKER_06]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_02]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then we will review it and let you know.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you, guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: something that we will let you all know that we're working on.
[SPEAKER_02]: We are sad and happy because it's a great opportunity for Bree.
[SPEAKER_02]: She is going to be making a move to the northwest area, she and her husband, and we wish her well and we appreciate what she's done here.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we do have a resolution here that basically is authorizing us or posting an advertisement for the position.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want me to read this or it is just,
[SPEAKER_02]: All the things that's involved in that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: A resolution of the Wright County Commission authorizing the immediate posting, advertisement, and hiring process for the position of road and bridge secretary.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whereas the current Road and Bridge Secretary for Ray County, Missouri has submitted notes of resignation and is scheduled to leave employment with the county within approximately three weeks.
[SPEAKER_02]: And whereas the Road and Bridge Secretary position is essential to the daily administrative operations of the Ray County Road and Bridge Department.
[SPEAKER_02]: And whereas the Ray County Commission recognizes the importance of beginning the hiring process immediately in order
[SPEAKER_02]: to provide an opportunity for the successful applicant to receive orientation and training from the outgoing employee.
[SPEAKER_02]: prior to departure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And whereas due to the limited time frame available, the commission finds it necessary in the best interest of the county to promptly advertise and begin accepting applications for the position.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now therefore be it resolved by the Ray County Commission as follows.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Ray County Commission hereby authorizes the immediate posting and advertisement of the Golden Bridge Secretary position.
[SPEAKER_02]: Notice of the opening shall be posted on the official public posting board outside the Ray County clerk's office on the official Ray County website and through such additional advertising methods as deemed appropriate by the commission, including publication in local newspapers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Applications shall be accepted until a deadline established by the commission or until the position is filled.
[SPEAKER_02]: Interviews for qualified applicants are anticipated to be conducted during the first week of June 2026.
[SPEAKER_02]: The commission authorizes the presiding commissioner, county clerk, and road and bridge
[SPEAKER_02]: department to coordinate the application review, interview, and hiring process in an effort to fill the position as quickly as possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: The commission further expresses its appreciation to the Afford Road and Bridge secretary for service provided to Ray County and wishes for success in future endeavors.
[SPEAKER_06]: I make a motion to accept the resolution as read.
[SPEAKER_06]: I second that.
[SPEAKER_06]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_06]: Aye.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would it be a symbol if we just said no?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, this was approved.
[SPEAKER_02]: How long have you been here?
[SPEAKER_02]: I've been here two years.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two years?
[SPEAKER_09]: I don't have enough time.
[SPEAKER_09]: Do we want to talk about it?
[SPEAKER_02]: I know you all are here, and we tabled the issue yesterday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are we ready to discuss that?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then do we have a comment?
[SPEAKER_02]: We reviewed what was in front of us.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think mainly we have to come to terms with the fact that it's not what we budgeted.
[SPEAKER_06]: Of course, it's got more locations and we have to determine what we're gonna do with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So at the moment, I'm gonna reject the bids, request rebidding after we get our stuff together and put together a tighter package and say bid this for us because it's past what we've budgeted for that and we're already tight.
[SPEAKER_10]: So it's only a $200 increase over what he's been doing.
[SPEAKER_10]: So then that was four years ago.
[SPEAKER_10]: Did he not make a $200 increase from four years ago?
[SPEAKER_06]: That's not what I saw.
[SPEAKER_10]: For the courthouse at Eagleton, what he's already doing?
[SPEAKER_10]: Not adding anything?
[SPEAKER_10]: The only reason he rebid was added the extra facilities is because you guys asked him about it throughout the year, you know, to do it.
[SPEAKER_10]: So he thought, well, maybe that's what they want.
[SPEAKER_10]: Is it facilities?
[SPEAKER_06]: Before we go any further, let's find out the actual number.
[SPEAKER_06]: What is our annual on that position, on that contracted work?
[SPEAKER_09]: What are we paying annually currently?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm working from memory, and you're probably working with real numbers, and so that's not good for me.
[SPEAKER_06]: And
[SPEAKER_06]: I might ask you to present it in a little different format.
[SPEAKER_06]: For example, five, three days, some of them I think would be two days.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not even sure we can get it in the public administrator's office.
[SPEAKER_10]: Do you even want, we don't even know, do you even want the public administrator's?
[SPEAKER_10]: Well, I.
[SPEAKER_10]: We don't really want to do it.
[SPEAKER_10]: I don't want to do it.
[SPEAKER_10]: Yeah, I don't want to do it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, we don't want to do it.
[SPEAKER_07]: We just want to satisfy you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: I thought you did so much down there and at the other two.
[SPEAKER_10]: They originally bidded only the courthouse, then they added the Eagleton, and then Glenda left off picking up the trash for the public administrator's office, so she said, okay, would you just do that for us?
[SPEAKER_10]: So then he's been picking up the trash for the public administrator's office.
[SPEAKER_10]: He didn't get paid for it, he just picks it up because she asked him to do it.
[SPEAKER_10]: But the contract has always been just the Eagleton and the courthouse.
[SPEAKER_10]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_10]: And like I said, the only reason we even gave you the option, the other two, was because we thought you wanted it.
[SPEAKER_10]: Otherwise, we would just
[SPEAKER_06]: But I'm assuming you're reading through this and knowing, well, I don't know, that's not quite.
[SPEAKER_10]: No, yeah, and it's a facility, so we didn't want to get caught off guard if we didn't go ahead and bid it, and you wanted it, so we were just trying to cover all bases.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay, okay, that makes sense.
[SPEAKER_07]: Does that make sense to you?
[SPEAKER_07]: Well, I was looking for option one.
[SPEAKER_10]: No, it's not option one.
[SPEAKER_10]: We're not doing that.
[SPEAKER_10]: It's option three, and I think it's only like a $240 a month raise.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you know, of course, we really would like option one at option three price.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, I know you would.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do understand that, right?
[SPEAKER_10]: But that would be like doing it for $50 an hour.
[SPEAKER_10]: And we provide all the bleeding stuff.
[SPEAKER_10]: I was just kidding.
[SPEAKER_10]: No, you weren't.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, no, you weren't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Could we table this and announce the decision next Thursday?
[SPEAKER_02]: So we've got some numbers.
[SPEAKER_02]: How about that?
[SPEAKER_06]: I have no problem whatsoever with what's been done and you do.
[SPEAKER_06]: and you do beautiful work, and I'd have to go complain whatsoever.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's just wrapping our head around it here.
[SPEAKER_06]: So let's do it next Thursday.
[SPEAKER_10]: Right, right.
[SPEAKER_06]: You might want to do that because the numbers look a little different to me here.
[SPEAKER_10]: And then just drop it off.
[SPEAKER_10]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_10]: And just forget about the other two buildings.
[SPEAKER_10]: Just focus on what we're doing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Just what I've been doing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, I just focus on it.
[SPEAKER_06]: If at some point we need to add a day or something, you know, we could do that based on what you're giving us.
[SPEAKER_10]: I'll try to make it more clear what it is.
[SPEAKER_06]: That'd be fine.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because this will end up being a contract.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we're doing this until next Thursday?
[SPEAKER_02]: We will make the decision next Thursday.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that we have a motion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, we don't have to.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we have to have a motion?
[SPEAKER_07]: I'd like the administrating office down there.
[SPEAKER_07]: They sent the trash out.
[SPEAKER_07]: You have to go by a dozen times.
[SPEAKER_07]: Like I went by Saturday all day.
[SPEAKER_07]: We can tighten that up.
[SPEAKER_07]: We for sure can tighten that up.
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, you're like, really?
[SPEAKER_02]: And maybe we just say, if you want your trash picked up, it needs to be here at this time.
[SPEAKER_02]: I went by Sunday morning, there's trash out.
[SPEAKER_02]: What?
[SPEAKER_07]: I went by here about four, five, six times Saturday.
[SPEAKER_07]: Because I was up here.
[SPEAKER_07]: We did the floors.
[SPEAKER_07]: We painted the stairs and all that.
[SPEAKER_07]: And every time I got out to go do something, we went by there to check.
[SPEAKER_07]: We went by there Sunday morning, come back up here, trash.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then we will, we're not in session on Wednesday, so that's why we won't do it Wednesday.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we will make the decision on Thursday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: Do we have anything else that we want to go over before we move on?
[SPEAKER_06]: Kurt, if it's a couple of weeks before we get to your ditch, is that going to be too late?
[SPEAKER_04]: No, I'm just trying to get it fixed.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, we've got a new machine coming in that does ditches specifically, so I may try to work with them on that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it's hard when I have two infants in the backseat and I can't pull in the driveway without them waking up because of how big this ditch is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.